all right this is a bit of an impromptu
council of geeks because so much has
happened in the last week or so in terms
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe that we
just need to sit down and talk about all
of it I guess we can try and go
chronological the first thing that
happened was ant-man
and Edgar Wright fled the scene leaving
a little Edgar Wright shaped dust cloud
behind him the shooting supposed to
beginning this summer
they've been fasting it I think yeah I
think it hit a lot of people hard
because he's been assigned to this for
so long and he was very outside of the
box director the project wouldn't exist
without Edgar Wright right people aren't
screaming for an ant-man movie yeah no
they're not the only reason it existed
as a project at all was because of him
yep I mean that that's like firing James
Cameron off of Avatar it's like well
what's the point now right I have a
feeling that what we'll find out is
through the development process they
gave him a ton of freedom but when it
came time to actually start rolling from
the cameras they were like Edgar we have
some notes I'm actually really nervous
by the fact that they're still gonna
shoot the movie yeah maybe I actually I
hope they don't I hope that they don't I
say they shelve it because I think
whatever we're gonna get in the end here
is not going to be at here's vision and
that doesn't mean that a movie that
isn't Edgar's wouldn't work I just think
we're gonna get this sort of twisted
version of that original story and it's
not gonna it's gonna be like Prometheus
sorry they could just grab somebody who
doesn't have the same passion or the
artistic vision and it could be well I
mean that first [ __ ] that's the problem
because the thing is is that the since
they're not moving the shooting date and
they're not moving the release date if
they bring somebody else in you know
everyone everyone who's turned down the
gig is claiming schedule conflicts and
maybe that's a genuine but I guarantee
you that someone their thought process
is also well you're not bringing me in
to make my movie you're bringing me in
to finish of the version of Edgar's
movie that you approve so which has
happened with that's basically what
happened with alien 3 they got David
Fincher as a last minute replacement all
had done before was music video like
for instance I can think that is
basically had this were like the this
train is moving just get a director on
it we end up with movies like The
Wolfman and x-men The Last Stand this is
the that's the level of quality we get
from this situation and I would rather
they just pull the plug at least on
terms of this iteration they either need
to pull the plug or they need to give up
that that starting time in that release
date and bring in someone and give them
the chance to make it something they're
comfortable with otherwise you know just
get just get a hack whole world the
camera hire McGee and call it a day
Marvel if you are listening I think all
three of us would love to take a whack
at ant-man put us together I think the
three of us you know we can do it I'll
write the My Little Pony fanfiction
version right online and that's gonna be
vital part of the viral marquee if you
don't have somebody on that already get
on that you're gonna need it seriously
nobody else wants to do it what else
have we got we have gotten I was gonna
say we've cast a nose but Thanos is
probably gonna be motion capture we have
a choice for Thanos a form of Josh
Brolin yep who it's not Tony top that's
that's really like if it wasn't Vin
Diesel I was like it's gonna be Tony
Todd or somebody of like I mean so the
our first you know if we're just gonna
go right into Josh Brolin I'm Jonah Hex
is I mean it's where I I know it's where
we have to I took after go there because
you know it's another comic book
universe and we've seen him sort of
playing a comic-book character in that
world
I was not terribly happy with Jonah Hex
I did I didn't even bother watching Joe
Hey here here's see I'm taking more long
lines of his performance as george w
bush the but i think here's the thing
and here's why i actually i don't
dislike josh brolin there's nothing
wrong with him but the best performances
that he's ever given have been
impersonations they've been george w
bush they bit they were in milk or they
are his
or many blame your wedding tommy was
active his best performances are not
completely his own it's his
reinterpretation of something that he
can very easily reference the stuff
where he's completely on his own I don't
I don't feel I don't feel like as an
actor he brings in tons of the table
again I only use a bad actor I just I
just can't get excited about it I say
how's it but then I would almost say
playing a role it's a knows where it's
gonna be some motion capture and voice
work it's almost it's almost a skill set
that we haven't seen him use so I don't
know if it'll be a problem for I don't
know if it's something he can't do I
don't think he's a bad casting choice I
just can't get excited about it yes we
have a director for Doctor Strange which
I guess I guess finally makes it
official that that they're actually
making it because they videos they've
been saying oh it's coming one of these
days what is it what we have a director
haha and scott derrickson yes yep yeah
who's the director of Exorcism of Emily
Rose a sinister sinister and the only
other guy he's done others but the only
other film I can think of is The Day the
Earth Stood Still three movies of which
I have not seen okay however just
hearing his pedigree is in the realm of
sci-fi horror impresses me because that
was what I was hoping what can you tell
us about so having seen all three of
those but just sort of looking at is
pedigree is a horror director the man
knows how to make a horror film I've
never felt like his films are cheap I
haven't feel like he's gone for those
cheap jumps so I've enjoyed I have
enjoyed his horror films and I think the
fact that he brings that particular
skill set on board is just it's super
exciting because I think the idea sort
of the problem with Doctor Strange right
is magic right and if you're gonna bring
magic into this universe that weaves
that is basically only a siphon Thor
which even then but they've gone out of
their way to explain that for isn't
magic it's just a science we don't
understand it's an alien and so it's
been a up to this point it's been a
world of science right right and so
Doctor Strange is a deviation from that
and so if you're gonna bring magic in
you
pretty high bar to meet in order to sort
of get us to swallow that and if it
comes off as Sabrina the Teenage Witch
raining and you're moving things and we
have talking cats we're gonna be upset
and so horror making it scary is a very
cool way to approach that I think that's
a good very good sign
now with that being said we also have
the day they're still with that one I
haven't seen yeah which was a giant
turkey they had the baggage of the fact
that the original film is such an iconic
you know piece of cinema and you're
going you have to compare them because
that's what you do and it does it failed
to live up to the original in many many
many ways he doesn't have that baggage
going into dr. French drop range is a
brand new property Marvel knows how to
treat this character we've seen the
arrogant self-absorbed character before
dr. Strange's origin is pretty much the
same as Tony Stark's in terms of
character beats yeah he just goes for a
different gimmick fan casting do you
have a hope for who you would like to
see in the role of dr. strange because
the latest rumor that's been going
around is Jared Leto no I would have
said the same thing you just won an
Academy Award for whatever that is I I'm
government very lengthy rant about his
role in that movie that I'm not gonna do
right now but no Jared you've been
warned no I'm not excited about that
idea if I could pick one that I haven't
heard attached to it um Richard Armitage
who plays Thorin Oakenshield in The
Hobbit movies he's actually he was my
fan cast pick to take over Batman after
Christian Bale completely selfishly and
there will be plenty of people on tumblr
who would like this but I would love to
put Benedict Cumberbatch in that role
and I think he would just own the pants
off of that part and he would I think he
would be amazing in it I don't have a
pic unfortunate I I will say though for
the love of God don't don't go Johnny
Depp don't go quirky don't go please no
not
not a knock against Johnny Depp
specifically I'm talking about like that
whole branch of Oh kind of kooky quirky
no no please take this one serious yeah
Daniel day-lewis serious for instance
when you get that daredevil
I mean it's kind of its kind of a short
thing because Charlie Cox was cast I
haven't seen Stardust I would like to
because I read the book when I was in
high school I loved it so I would like
to see that movie sometime in a bit of
serendipity I've been catching up on
Boardwalk Empire and I saw his first
episode in that show about two hours
before the news broke I'm so when I saw
Charlie Cox listen wait where do I know
that from I had to go back a night so
I've been watching him on that show for
a couple days and my first thought when
I heard about it was he can play haunted
irish-catholic
which is half the role of Matt Murdock
yeah oh yeah if he watch his performance
in Boardwalk Empire he's not in
over-the-top you know a sort of
character actor he I mean he's playing
there's a lot of subtlety to his
performance you know he commands the
attention of the screen when he's on it
um I I I'm kind of excited about this I
my you to be like a good job with this
my first instinct was kind of yeah I
would have gone a different direction
but every day since I've been like yeah
I like this I like this direction I'm
excited for this and the other thing
that is sort of really exciting for me
is that I would honestly this is sort of
a blanket statement but I think the best
sort of entertainment that's being
produced right now is on TV and it's not
on film and I think that TV series and I
think you can point to any number of
them Breaking Bad Game of Thrones and
the list goes on and on this will give
them room to grow this character sure
and it's not going to be a two-hour
movie it's going to be a 12 or 13 our
movement yeah in the same realm of this
kind of takes it's almost full circle
back to the editor right thing the the
showrunner behind
daredevil also stepped out a few days
later yeah drew guard him step out but
but that did seem to be more of a
scheduling thing because he's still
staying on as a consultant he didn't
completely walk away the way ago right
completely walked him right and he
walked away for movie money from Sony
because he's he's directly is it the
sinister six intersect
which wrong call drew wrong call yeah
whatever um but yeah baby that we are
like we could be possibly less excited
about then um Batman versus Superman
dawn of Justice no because because that
has no potential to really be I mean
correct amazing right I mean Sabrina
actually show off in this movie too his
name isn't the title so I would expect
but you know the the the sinister six
movie I need I don't understand why it's
a thing that is going to exist like I
you know complained all you all you want
about the Batman supermen they're
cramming too much in it's just a Justice
League prequel it's not so men's movie
in all valid I'm sure but I understand
why it exists sure I do not understand
why we live in a world that is going to
have a sinister six movie right
and where are people who like these
properties and these characters yeah and
we're having a hard time understanding
why you want us to watch this movie who
excited by reading bored I like
spider-man stories with the sinister six
right and I almost did a spit their only
choice is gonna be you're gonna have to
give us somebody to root for which means
you're gonna have to fundamentally
change one of these characters or one of
them is very good or one of them is
gonna be more sinister as the sinister
six that has a very Stanley ring to it
doesn't it you can see that flash it
across a Jack Kirby cover we have run
this thing into the ground so we'll wrap
it up there and until next time this
council is adjourned
I'll have to cut this but I was talking
to Thomas
oh yeah and the whole thing where it's
not even